guys I just came back from watching
Mission Impossible rogue nation holy
[ __ ] let's talk about this [ __ ] how does
he do it
how does he do it like when you runs
he's this posture is just beautiful it's
perfect anyway yeah Tom Cruise has yet
again proved that he is probably the
best action star around right now the
dudes in his 50s but he still looks like
he's in his like early forties late 30s
maybe regardless he still looks [ __ ]
sexy I'd [ __ ] Tom Cruise I'd [ __ ]
read that Scientology [ __ ] man anyway
look Mission Impossible five the basic
plot revealed in the trailers is that
there is a secret organization called
The Syndicate which is as powerful and
as skilled as the IMF but they're like
the bad version but from beginning to
end this film just [ __ ] rocked man
first couple minutes I'm already so glad
I'm in the theaters that scene they keep
showing in the trailer where he's
hanging off the airplane and while the
airplane is up in the air that is such a
good opening right up front we get an
established set of characters a sense of
intensity yet fun and from there on in
you're just hooked for the right man the
Tom Cruise right it's a clever film
there's a lot more plot twist this time
around there's more mystery to the
puzzle it's just an awesome like spy
thriller like it feels like a spy film
it's [ __ ] awesome in a way to me it
combined elements of Mission Impossible
3 with Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
mi3 was very dark very serious very
personal Ghost Protocol was like this
fun action-adventure spy flick so they
still made a fun action adventure spy
flick but they added some darkness to
there some serious tones even though the
plot may not be as personal as it is for
a mission impossible 3 it still feels
like this is personal I mean there are
familiar elements we've seen before
IMF being shut down IMF going after
Ethan Hunt but rather than making it
some twist early into the film this CIA
is hunting Ethan Hunt
like from the beginning which already
gives it a more personal vibe no one in
the CIA believes that there's a secret
organization called The Syndicate yeah
ethan is hunting to take down the
syndicate and our CIA is hunting Ethan
so we get an extra layer to this
character like you see Ethan hunts like
true survivor side of him like the
survivor on the run a fugitive it's a
cool sight to see he's out for vengeance
he's out for what's right but it also
deals with like really pushing him to
his limits and even him was sort of
becoming like obsessive with the mission
like I had no I'm pointing out serious
stuff but this movie is a lot of fun
like I had a I had a I had a big [ __ ]
smile on my face it was good
like for starters Simon Pegg as Benji
awesome I don't want to give anything
away but they do evolve his character
they make things even more personal with
him and Tom Cruise there's humor and
he's subtle with his humor like I said
the I thing it's always like there's
good moments of back and forth some even
physical type of comedy but this movie
has like great intensity too like
there's moments that are very
suspenseful that scene we seen the
trailer of Tom Cruise diving into the
water I don't want to give the details
away but wow that was a really intense
scene like that moment in the film is
when it took the time to become like
gravity and just immerse you into this
experience Christopher McQuarrie is the
director of this film and he directed
Jack Reacher I personally wasn't that
into the Jack Reacher although I do have
a hilarious joke
Jack Reacher to Jack Reacher around I
know I could have delivered that one
better but I really did like Jack
Reacher's kind of just thinking about
Jack jacking off but the car chase scene
in Jack Reacher was really [ __ ] cool
and he's done it again with this film
hands down this is the best car chase
sequence out of the whole franchise in
the car so the motorcycles but not just
that there's such an important reason
for why this fight is going on right now
that you're doing more than just like oh
that's an that's cool or oh sweet like
you're really pulled into the moment the
great action beyond that that's what you
know we expect and they certainly
deliver there but I just thought the
writing to was very clever like there
like I said earlier there's a lot more
plot twist there's a lot more plot turns
and not just Ethan Hunt alone they they
sort of flesh out every
once characters a little bit better what
I love that they did was they took the
best characters out of Mission
Impossible 3 and Ghost Protocol and put
them all together so you got Simon Pegg
on the team you got jeremy renner on the
team and you got ving rhames of course
I'm gonna look like a total racist
because I forgot the black guys name for
a second I'm sorry it doesn't make me a
racist and Jeremy Renner's character
he's caught in this position of working
for the CIA
so he's hunting Ethan but at the same
time he's not hunting Ethan he's trying
to like save and protect him my only
issue with this character of the film
was nothing that they did with the
character it was something I just wanted
to see more of I wanted to see more
Jeremy Renner kicking ass like we know
Jeremy Renner can kick ass and they
showed us that in Ghost Protocol he can
kick ass I did not really see him kick
ass in this film I would have liked to
have seen him kicking some ass he kicks
ass in other ways but not in the martial
art kind of way being reims is great you
know he's such a charming touch to the
franchise because he's like that big
teddy bear you want to hug unless he
plays gangsters then he's just [ __ ]
scary Luther was part of the team from
mi 1 to mi 3 and then he made a cameo at
the end of Ghost Protocol but it's cool
that they brought him back as one of the
main supporting characters and it's
awesome to just see these three dudes
together man it's really cool plus Tom
Cruise leaving them it's awesome
so if there's great acting in this film
- but the real surprise of the film was
actress Rebecca Ferguson I think I got
her name right like you got to give
kudos to the writing of the character
because they actually gave her a
character she was more than just sexy
appeal for the movie or just a woman who
can kick ass like they gave her a real
character with real depth I can't give
her character away but damn she is
complex and it's fascinating
yes she's sexy she's sad she like wears
a mask emotional mass not one of the
Mission Impossible masks interaction
moments are [ __ ] fantastic yeah yeah
I want to have a threesome with her and
Veronica that would be really cool and
Alec Baldwin is also great I love what
they did with this character this
character could have easily been someone
who just stayed that one note throughout
the whole [ __ ] film you know like oh
this is just the guy who wants IMF
shutdown and by the end of the movie
he's probably gonna realize IMF is a
good thing but they do more with it than
you'd expect there's actually a few
surprises to the character it's cool
because they really showed us why they
specifically cast Alec Baldwin it wasn't
just about putting another famous person
in the movie it's like yeah Alec Baldwin
is a really good choice for that role
yeah this movie's a blast it's super
[ __ ] fun it's super intense there's
great action great character Tom Cruise
continuously proves that he's not that
old and Christopher McQuarrie I was
worried about him directing this got to
be honest about that but dude you have
left all doubts out the way I basically
I'm wrong yeah
the dude didn't know he directed he also
wrote this fits yeah it's a pretty cool
film and I guess some reviews not
complete unless you have a rating some
people are like I don't know what you
feel about it if there isn't a ratings
what it's pretty obvious how I feel
about I don't know Mission Impossible
rogue nation got 5 out of 5 Ryan Dix
there you go anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter Lyon and
periscope and I want to give a shout out
because this is a good [ __ ] movie and
I hope more people are watching this
sue jgs hey Ryan
I'm a new subscriber and by the new I
mean that I literally subscribe to you
like a couple of days ago in these two
days I probably watched around a hundred
videos hello well you and tyronn are
probably the two best reactors out there
thanks we work hard at being ourselves
while watching videos and the fact that
you're a fan of eminem is really amazing
I'm a hardcore shady fan myself anyway
thanks for all the amazing content hope
to see many more in the future oh and
say hi to Veronica bye sue J thank you
so much for subscribing I'm glad you're
new you know people when they're fairly
new might not get my sense of humor so
I'm probably gonna go a little bit light
on you for this shout out but sue J also
rhymes with you gay and CJ it's okay to
be gay
I just want you to know that it's
totally fine no need to feel ashamed
it's legal in all 50 states now there's
a reason why because there's nothing
wrong with it sue GA the gay